thank you
for joining us
thank you for joining us this evening on
our latest installment in
in bad this great
book of really just comprises
the heart and the
most important parts of the sunnah of
the prophet salallahu
not just the most important parts but
nearly every aspect of the prophet
sallallahu alaihis life
to the best of the ability of its author
and its author's ability was very
awesome and
exceptional so this book was authored by
shem sadin
and he wrote this book on his way to
hajj traveling
he had no references he had no books
with him and everything that he wrote
was from memory
five volumes in total over 3
000 pages and he quoted from over 200
different sources
and almost comprised the entirety of the
sunnah of the prophet
along with detailed arguments
detailed
issues of hadith and minutia with
regards to filk and differences of
opinion
and so forth and so
of course subsequently
this book henceforth became the
reference point of
anyone who wrote about the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was an exceptional mind of the islamic
world and the islamic scholarship
and one in
probably about
one in a few very very rare
minds that are as bright
and as broad and as well researched and
well
gifted to be able to write such a work
and so even the most comprehensive books
and the most major of scholars of islam
after
would refer and reference his book
and that is with regards to anything
having to do with the sunnah of the
prophet
alaihi wasallam issues of hadith issues
of
seerah if issues of
issues of differences or
seeming contradictions issues that
he was very good with
harmonizing all of the narrations in the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and so
tonight insha allah and probably the
week to follow
we are going to be discussing the issue
of
illness and how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would visit
and tend to the ill
so visiting the ill
which is referred to as
that you were to visit the ill
and try to console the ill
this is something which is an obligation
upon each muslim upon his brother or
sister
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
famously in the narration in sahih
al-bukhari
that the right of the muslim upon the
muslim are five
and one narration he list them as five
and one of them
if he falls ill then you are to go to
visit him
to console him to
make contact with him if a person has
some kind of infectious disease
that it can be transmitted things like
we've seen recently with the coronavirus
or other
ailments that can be easily transmitted
airborne
viruses and so forth a person doesn't
have to go in person this can be
accomplished alhamdulillah
by merely contacting the person via
telephone or text message or email or
any of these things
person can even have conversations on
video chat
to make sure that they instill
in their brother and their sick sister
their sick brother
a sense of community a sense of love
a sense of togetherness
that you are ill and by your illness we
are pained
and we recognize your illness
we miss you and we hope the best for you
as an act of good will one muslim to the
other
and this is something which is
unfortunately dropped off and become
very superficial
in our time a person might fall ill
they'll get the
run-of-the-mill
text message how are you doing i heard
you're sick i hope you feel better
i mean and
visiting the ill is a lot more involved
than just mere superficial
dua superficial i mean the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
would visit anybody that was ill
as long as he had the ability and the
capacity to visit them
if he heard that this person was ill
even if it was an infant
even if it was a baby in order to
console the parents
of the child this is important
it's important that the person
is instilled with a sense of comfort
it's not enough to merely just say
you know i hope you feel better blah
blah blah
may allah heal you i mean this kind of
thing this kind of superficiality
is not sufficient
with regards to visitation of the ill
visitation of the ill is much more
involved
than that there is an element
of consoling the person
seriously listening to the person not
just feeling you have some
thing you have to say just to make
yourself feel better it's all about
making the sick
the person who is ailing feel better and
most of that has to do with not speaking
at all and actually listening
that a person may have some complaint a
person may have some
venting to do and that you would sit
there and listen and you would be amazed
the amount of relief that a person can
gain by a single
nod of recognition from you
if you just merely listen to them
undistracted
and nod your head recognizing and
validating their
pain or validating their hardship
this works wonders with regards to
release of emotion and giving bolstering
a person's
confidence and a person who is ill
has to maintain confidence has to
maintain
strength a fighting
a fighting and a surviving
mindset in order to survive the illness
or at least remain
optimistic during the illness remain
optimistic with allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and as we are in the earth allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and he referred to
as a khalifa in the earth a successor
in and a representative
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the
earth
so when the muslims show up to visit the
ill
or when they reach out to visit the ill
it should not be just merely
some superficial glazed over
get well card this is not enough this is
not what is required when you are
visiting your brother or sister
or you're making contact with him or her
what is required is to console the
person
to show solidarity
so to show support to show sincere
recognition of this person's hardship
and this person's pain
and this person's tribulation this is
why the per
prophet salallahu alaihi was said
that the believers are one body
if one part is in pain the rest of the
body reacts
and suffers from fever and insomnia
why because the rest of the body is
affected honestly
truly affected by what ails this
finger or this toe or the ear or any
extremity or any organ so it's important
that we
understand that we keep the spirit of
visiting the ill this is something that
we have slipped into a kind of
complacency
kind of when we ask each other how
are you we don't really
listen to the answer we say how you
doing
how is it going how is your family et
cetera et cetera
we're just going down a list why because
this is what is proper
but very few people actually listen
to the answers and because of that there
is a growing sense
of loneliness amongst the
muslims and there is a fragmentation
between them these are the kinds of acts
which speak much more profoundly than
words do if we look at the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's life
and we look at 23 years of
prophethood 23 years as a prophet
imagine 23 years with companions like
the companions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam how much could he have
said
and how much could he have done in 23
years if you were to document for
example
just your words for one year how many
pages would it fill
how many volumes would it fill how many
gigabytes
of data would that be yet when we look
at
the time that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam spent
as a prophet and a messenger of allah
and we look at the dutifulness of his
companions
in documenting everything that he said
and did and did not do right
and we take all of that into account
we see there's a disparity between the
amount of time he was a profit and the
amount of information that we have
the information that we have seems to be
relatively low
lower than you would expect right
so authentic narrations without
repetition
not counting the chains of narration
that are authentic
are a little less than forty thousand
authentic narrations
forty thousand authentic statements or
actions or
reactions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam documented
over 23 years that's not that many when
you think about it
what do we understand from this well we
understand that
number one most of the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam's teachings were
repetitive
he would say the same thing in different
ways on different
settings in different environments to
different people
over and over and over in order that
people
would have this instilled
a sense of what he is trying to convey
number two most of what he did was with
his actions
we would see that he would speak very
little
compared to what he would do he would do
a lot
and he would speak very little most of
what we have
are by the way statements that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
make
or some
or addresses that he would address the
people with
in general and the quran
the rest is his actions the way that he
carried himself
and this was very uniquely repetitive
and that is the hallmark of a good
a good teacher a good teacher is
repetitive
of the basics right and a good
student is fervent in understanding and
rehearsing and reviewing
the basics this is what is most
important in order to attain
mastery so
most of his
most of the people that were inspired by
him were not as
inspired by his words as they were by
his
actions by his attitude by his
character by what he did not say what he
did
right slight issues slight movements the
way he would walk the way he would
conduct himself and so when he would go
to visit someone
the prophet alaihi wasallam is a general
he is a father
he is a husband he is the most busy
human being
that there is not a moment of his time
was in waste
right you could never ever be more busy
than the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam and his companions a lot of
people
they kind of imagine the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and the time of the companions as being
very relaxed
laid back not much to do you know you're
just kind of walking around
and sitting under shade shade the shade
of trees and hanging out
this is couldn't be further from the
truth the most busy people
right the most packed agendas the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam had an
entire
ummah that was resting on his shoulders
let alone those who were to follow and
he
articulated the immensity
of this endeavor to his companions and
they took it seriously
equally as serious and so
they would not waste a moment in jest
and so in spite of this he would
find time to visit the sick visit
children when they became ill visit
old very old people visit non-muslims
when they would fall ill
if there was some if there was some
hope that these people might accept
islam et cetera as we will get into
inshallah
what i want to really
really drive home here is that there
should not be
just a topical glazed over
approach when we deal with our brothers
and sisters
there should be a sincere earnest
heartfelt
heartfelt gestures
in dealing with our brothers and sisters
what does that mean
meaning that when we make dua for our
brothers and sisters and say something
as passive as
[Arabic recitation]
dua
not just as a superficial this is what
i'm supposed to say therefore i say it
under these circumstances to be polite
and it has no meaning
this is not what the ummah of islam
was built upon we were a nation
of a nation
that was not superficial rather a
nation of quality and substance
everything that we say
everything that we do comes from the
heart
right everything that we refuse
everything that we do not do
comes from the heart this is could not
be driven home
could not be more important to us
to understand and so
we will now after this prelude we will
now
or this preface we will now get into the
way that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would deal with
visiting the ill and the sick right
when we say things to each other
i heard you're sick you know and
people deal
deal with illness and deal with tragedy
in different ways
some people they really desire support
from their brothers and sisters and
they're really open
and some people during times of tragedy
or hardship they kind of close off and
they want their privacy and all of this
is to be expected people deal with
things in different ways
sometimes there are people when they
become ill they would rather not
have so many visitors they would rather
just be
left to their contemplativeness or their
family members
and there are some who would desire
people to visit them more and
are more are felt feel more at ease
and that is the point
so when we go to visit someone or reach
out to someone we need to gauge
their enthusiasm to this gesture what
would make
them feel better would it make them feel
better if i just called
would it be better for them if i
showed up
would it be better if i brought other
people with me should i come on
my own should i send condolences
should i call them or is a mere message
more something that this person would
and each person is different
so we have to respect that as well and
we shouldn't feel
this is something personal
people are different
different people deal with things
differently
there are some people who are more
private and we should respect that
and there are some people who are more
social
and extroverted and we should
understand that as well so when it comes
to
dealing with our brothers and sisters in
times of hardship we gauge
what is better for them not what is more
convenient or better for me
allah says about the prophet salallahu
he used to always visit
anyone who fell ill from amongst his
companions
and he also was narrated to have visited
a young boy who used to serve him from
the people of the book a young jewish
boy
and this jewish boy actually accepted
islam
and his final breaths
and also his uncle abu talib when he
fell ill and he was on his deathbed
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
went to visit him as well
and he
invited both of them to islam
and the young jewish boy accepted islam
and as we know abu talib
died as a non-muslim as a disbeliever
he says and he used to come close
to the person who is sick to the person
who was ill the person he was visiting
if it is not a contagious disease if it
is not something that would
put him in danger or put his companions
in danger he would come
close to the person who is ill way
edgeless
and he would sit close to the person's
head meaning
expecting this is of course in the case
where a person is laid down
he wouldn't sit at the edge of the in
the corner of the room or
far away as if you know i don't want to
touch you i don't want to come near you
he would show
that closeness and that sincere
earnest concern for the person
so he would come close to the person and
sit up close to the person's head
and he would ask the person how do you
feel how are you
what is ailing you how are you feeling
and this is something i want to make
sure that we understand when you ask
these
questions listen to the response
right actually listen don't just hear
the person and go on with your
conversation
sometimes the best conversation and the
most rewarding
thing you could do for your muslim
brother or sister is just to listen
to listen even for a half an hour or an
hour you listen to them
attentively as you would want others to
listen to you
if you were venting right
and it's sad because now we have
therapists and shrinks and
psychologists that we pay money to
for them for someone to listen to us so
we pay them money so we can sit
and talk and hear them
just to see somebody listening to us
right
people are going on forums and going on
chat rooms and just to
get stuff off of their chest and have
somebody listen to them or somebody
somebody recognize their
pain or discomfort or calamity or
hardship or conundrum or whatever it is
right so a lot of times we fail to
listen
and listening is one of the most
important things you can do
sometimes even myself or
anybody else a person of knowledge or
there's
times when i you know your problem is
something that i can't
help you with right
whatever the problem is it could be a
personal problem that's something that
you have to overcome and there's no one
else who can do it for you
and i can't fix your problems for you
but at least i can listen and
i may have something to say and i may
not
right if a person asks for advice
i may have good advice for them and i
may not
i may say you know i i may listen
and at the end come to realize that
this is something beyond my realm or
something
that i have nothing positive or anything
constructive to say
and the prophet salallahu
believes in allah in the last day then
he is to speak with good or remain
silent
but you can at least listen to a
person's
hardships and they will be very grateful
to you for that
so when you're listening to someone
don't try to take over the conversation
and try to give them oh
you should just do this this this and
this and you'll be fine
right sometimes that that is actually a
more frustrating response
because they're not asking you
necessarily for you to fix their problem
for you
for them or they're not asking you
they're just asking you to listen to
them
and it seems simple enough but it's
actually very hard to find someone who
is good at listening
right
he says
and he would sometimes take his right
hand
and wipe over the
head of the person who
is ailing and he would make dua for the
person
[Arabic recitation]
allah lord of the people
do away with thee calamity and
ailment
and please heal them you are the healer
there is no healing but yours
shife
and your healing is a healing that
does not leave behind any
ailment if you so will
and he would make this
and often he would make dua for the
person who is ailing three times in
threes
kamakala allah
one of his companions was ill-sad and he
[Arabic recitation]
it three times oh allah
please heal
and when he would go to visit the ill
one of his standard statements that he
would say
statements of encouragement to the
ailing
person to the sick person is that he
would say
no problem this will be a purification
for you by allah's will
right no problem this will be a
purification
for you by allah's will
meaning that you are in a state of
hardship and a state of illness
but don't worry this is not going
unrecognized and your pain and suffering
is not
unrecognized by allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
so you will be rewarded for this and
this will be an expiation for your sins
by the will of allah so again back to
this optimistic approach the glass is
half
empty the glass is half full yes you are
ill
but your illness is not ingested it's
not for no good reason
and so he would instill these kinds of
concepts
into the person who was ill
he would say
this is an expiation and a purification
for you
[Silence]
and sometimes he would perform
rupiah on the person who is ailing
a person who had an infection or a
person who was
dealing with a mortal wound
or some kind of ailment the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would place his index
finger in the dirt
and then he would raise it up and say
bismillah in the name of allah
by thee by the
dirt of our land and
by the spittle of
some of us of of ours this will
be a cause for the healing
of our ailing by the will of our lord
and this is a type of that the prophet
salallahu salem would perform
he would do this in medina medina is a
land that is mubarak
and what he means by spital is that when
a person does rukia that they
they do this kind of blowing
of on the person who is ailing and
then recite the quran
and this is how he would perform rookia
allah
so thank you for joining us for our half
hour this evening
alhamdulillah every evening
we get together and we discuss the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
he was
25 or 30 minutes we
learn something new and hopefully this
can
can be a catharsis and an
aid for all of us on our journey and a
provision for the hereafter insha allah
for all of us
allah